Мене звати Софія Лапіна. Я - правозахисниця та представниця ЛГБТК-спільноти.
Та зазнала нещодавно чергових в своєму житті погроз власному життю та переслідувань.
31-річна Софія Лапіна очолює громадську організацію "УкраїнаПрайд"
У середині липня її персональні дані - номер телефону та прив'язані до нього месенджери -
оприлюднили в телеграм-каналі однієї з ультраправих організацій, що налічує 12 000 підписників.
За кілька днів прихильники гомофобського руху надіслали Софії понад 200 повідомлень.
Пробували зламати навіть її банківські рахунки і відкрито погрожували її життю.
Мені надіслали декілька повідомлень з прямими погрозами, що ми тебе знайдемо, вб’ємо. Будь обережна, ходи по вулиці та озирайся.
І одне з повідомлень - надіслали фото мого балкону, написали,  що, мовляв, мені пора провітрити кишки.
Софія звернулася з двома заявами до поліції - про незаконне оприлюднення її персональних даних та у зв’язку з погрозами.
Однак поліція зареєструвала заяви не одразу, а після наполегливих повторних звернень. Також не відкрила кримінальне провадження.
Софія вже не вперше має справу з погрозами на адресу представників ЛГБТК та реакцією на них правоохоронців.
Адже у неї за плечима - майже шестирічний досвід правозахисної діяльності.
За цей час, констатує жінка, скептичне ставлення правоохоронців до проблем цих людей не змінилося.
Сказати, що незахищені - це не сказати нічого. Тому що добре, коли я правозахисниця.
Зі мною коли поліція спілкується вже з риторики, з самого діалогу, вони розуміють, що це не та людина, якій  можна нагрубити
або сказати там, мовляв, "пі…р", йди звідси, як  вони дуже  часто кажуть ЛГБТ-людям,  на яких напали і пишуть заяву.
І вони кажуть, та, що  тебе побили, бо ти гей? В поліції можуть посміятися та сказати, мовляв, йди звідси.
Клубний перформер та ЛГБТК-активіст Владислав Шаст не приховував і не приховує, що є геєм. Він дуже переймається про безпеку Софії Лапіної.
Адже з власного досвіду знає, як бути один на один з агресивно налаштованими проти ЛГБТК людьми.
У мене нещодавно в самого трапилася історія.  На мене напали декілька підлітків в ТГ "Оушен плаза". Я викликав поліцію.
По-перше, поліція мене відмовляла писати заяву. Тому що, це ж діти. Але ж діти  можуть підійти та вдарити з кулака в голову.
Ці підлітки мені казали…. Пряма мова: "Та ти "пі…р"! Я буду піз… тебе! І ніхто мені нічого не зробить, тому що ти - "пі…с"! Захочу і "н…ра" буду мочить!
За даними ООН, в Україні лише з серпня 2020-го року по січень 21-го сталося майже 18 нападів на представників ЛГБТК-спільноти -
активістів, журналістів, правозахисників. Лапіна запевняє, що подібних випадків у побутовому житті набагато більше.
Не кажучи вже про прояви дискримінації при працевлаштуванні, навчанні тощо.
Просто не всі, як вона, ризикують звернутися до правоохоронців і мають сили добиватися від них реакції.
Характерно, що історія з оприлюдненням її телефону та погрозами сталась якраз у період, коли ЛГБТК-організації
готувалися до Прайд-місяця та Маршу рівності в серпні.
Саме цього літа ЛГБТК-спільнота активно проводить й інформаційну компанію на підтримку законопроєкту, який запровадить посилену адміністративну,
а також нарешті кримінальну відповідальність за утиски й дискримінацію усіх вразливих груп населення, не лише ЛГБТК.
Він, зокрема, вводить відповідальність за публічні заклики до насильства на ґрунті нетерпимості та умисні дії, спрямовані на розпалювання ворожнечі.
Ганьба! Ганьба!
Це одні з затятих опонентів ЛГБТК-руху. Вони прийшли, аби зупинити акцію ЛГБТК біля Офісу президента на підтримку цього законопроєкту.
Обидва табори розділяє посилений кордон правоохоронців.
Софія Лапіна кілька останніх років виконувала роль комунікатора з поліцією, коли в Києві проходив черговий Прайд.
Розповідає, що навіть стоячи за спинами озброєних спецпризначенців, не можна бути впевненими, що крізь них не прорвуться агресивні люди.
Цього разу її адвокати вирішили надати їй персональну охорону.
Я відчуваю себе, як у фільмі "Тілоохоронець".
Відчуваю себе безпечно, гарний досвід. Але хотілося би , щоб він не повторювався, тому що мені здається,
я не роблю нічого такого, за що можна зазіхати на моє життя та свободу.
ЛГБТК-спільнота об’єдналася з представниками технокультури. В урядовому кварталі гучно лунає електронна музика від відомих діджеїв.
Це акція протесту проти бездіяльності влади. Проходить біля Офісу президента.
Адже саме до нього як до гаранта Конституції вони адресують свій головний меседж.
Щоб вони нас почули. Вони не можуть нас почути через якісь акції мирні, через якісь рухи, марші. Тому ми лупанемо їм звук під вікнами.
Щоб вони… Ой, а що це там відбувається. Доброго дня! Скажемо ми. Привіт! Ми тут! Захистіть нас.
Ми розуміємо, що прогрес рухається набагато повільніше, ніж міг би на практиці.
Кримінальне законодавство не змінюється і трішки лицемірно виглядає, що Україна комунікує проєвропейську позицію.
Чому президент Володимир Зеленський не вітає  з Прайдом хоча б ЛГБТ спільноту?
Можна подивитися щороку, коли проходить Марш за права жінок.
І ті ж самі радикали прибігають поливати жінок зеленкою і прискають балончиком в очі. Їм не важливо, хто ти.
Чоловік-гей, лесбійка, або жінка, яка хоче сказати, що вона більше, ніж машина домогосподарча. В мене є  права!
ЛГБТК-спільноту підтримують інші громадські організації, звичайні кияни. Адже агресія проти людей, які чимось відрізняються, неприпустима.
Я не належу до ЛГБТК-спільноти. Я підтримую, тому що хочу ходити по вулицях Києва в будь-якому вигляді,
з будь якими людьми поруч, і не боятися  що за свою безпеку.
Я не розумію, нащо погрожувати людям за те, що вони люди!
Я гетеросексуальна. В мене хлопець є. ЛГБТК потребує захисту. В нас ще пострадянське  виховання залишилося.
І не всі готові приймати людей такими, як вони є. Толерантність не поширена.
Мого друга побили за те, що він йшов ввечері та прикрасив обличчя  блискітками. Але в цьому нічого поганого не було ж!
Дбати про захист сексуальних меншин Україна зобов’язалася відповідно до підписаної Угоди про Асоціацію з ЄС.
Однак напади на представників ЛГБТК свідчать про цілком проблемну ситуацію.
Права людини в Україні часто не захищені, справжні реформи у правоохоронній та судовій системі відсутні, переконана правозахисниця Софія Лапіна.
Вона розпочала свою правозахисну діяльність у 2016-му, коди на захід, який вона організувала в Чернівцях,
прийшли люди спортивної статури і заявили, що вони його забороняють.
Софія вважає, що подібного в демократичній державі не може бути. Попри загрозу для свого життя, вона з колегами зупинятися не збираються.
Якщо по-простому, то якщо ти напав на гея через те,  що він гей, то це так саме, як  нападають на темношкірих. Це  називається злочин на ґрунті ненависті.
Якщо кримінальне законодавство буде працювати, то в нас різко зміниться ситуація з правами ЛГБТ.
Тому що всі інституції і праворадикали будуть знати, що вони не можуть порушувати права цієї спільноти.
Якщо ухвалять законопроект проти дискримінації, це убезпечить від агресивно налаштованих спільнот і інші верстви населення.
Адже за це буде передбачена кримінальна відповідальність.
Особливо це важливо в регіонах подалі від столиці, каже Софія, де поліція зовсім не реагує на такі шокуючі інциденти.